thank you so much for talking to us this
is a
slightly peculiar unusual way of doing
an interview
um we are living in very unusual times
at the moment um i wanted to start off
by
asking you what have been your
reflections
of the the impact that this pandemic has
had
on our country well as i've tried to say
in one or two
messages to different groups of people
in this country i can
i can't tell you how much i sympathize
with the way
everybody has had to endure this
unbelievably testing
and challenging time and i i i know that
so many people have
had the agony of losing you know their
loved ones
and the bewilderment and anxiety that
surrounds everything
and so
[Music]
it is the most awful aspect of a
pandemic like this and
and yet we've seen at the same time
people being quite remarkable
and wonderful people in the national
health service and all the other key
workers who kept everything going and
that is
the remarkable thing about this it
always produces the best in everybody in
so many ways and
that i think is is something which is
which is so special about
about the reaction but at the same time
uh we have to make sure we try to do
better in the future
it has it's been remarkable to see the
um the community spirit that has really
come out right across the country but
but what do you think it has
taught us about our priorities what
really matters
in life at the moment yes well i think
i think more and more people perhaps
have begun to realize that
that all sorts of things we never really
thought about perhaps
as much as we should have done are
absolutely crucial for instance
as i've tried to say for i did nearly 40
years that
we we have to put nature back at the
center of
everything we do and put it at the
center of our economy which is
before this it's been nature's has been
pushed to the
peripheries we've exploited and dug up
and cut down everything as if there was
no tomorrow
if it didn't matter the problem is of
course it does matter as
some people have been trying to say for
a long time the more we
erode the natural world the more we
destroy
what's called biodiversity which is the
immense diversity of life
plant life tree life everything else
marine life
the the more we expose ourselves to this
kind of
danger and we've had these other
disasters you know with um sars and
ebola and goodness knows what else all
of these things
are related to the loss of biodiversity
they're called
zoonotic diseases where uh you end up
with
with these diseases being transferred
from animals to to humans
if you over uh erode
the natural world so we have to find a
way this time
to put nature back at the center and
that is the way in which if we live in
greater harmony we can find a
much more sensible form of economy
it's fascinating what you say there
because i know that we've spoken in the
past about
your concerns that if we don't act now
we are going to see
more natural disasters but but you're
also saying that that we could see
more pandemics like this well this is
what so many of the
scientists who understand these things
have been trying to say for a long time
and i mean it's one of the reasons i
tried to to get the point across
that we should have been treating the
planet as if it was a patient
long ago so no self-respecting doctor
would ever have let the situation if the
planet is a patient
reach this stage before making an
intervention
hence you know the um precautionary
principle which seems to be absolutely
essential
and and also learning from all those
indigenous people around the world who
understand these issues only too well
and also understand that certain things
are sacred if you see what i mean
but we've removed all that sense totally
from
our scheme of things and i think you
know we're slightly paying
the price as a result how concerned are
you that if we don't
take radical action now we we could see
another pandemic like this many people
never expected to see anything like this
in their lifetime
well i mean i am extremely concerned
again
why you know when i went to the world
economic forum gathering in davos in
january i was trying to
trying to outline a ten point action
plan for how to
do all these things better now and
since then since january of course the
situation has got far
far worse and we have you know
countless millions of people around the
world
in incredibly difficult circumstances
millions out of work uh all around the
commonwealth let alone anything else
and the economic impact let alone the
impact from the
pandemic is is immense so
we the point about it is how do we
create a better
system there are there's all sorts of
things that people have been trying to
say for a long time that we could do
much better
and and these are the things that we
have to concentrate on now it seems to
me
in order to to to to work our way out of
this
but in a far better and more sustainable
way that actually puts a green
recovery at the center of all this and
the great thing if i may say so is
there's more and more consensus building
around
what needs to be done now and suddenly
we find with people taking interest who
never did before
in your earth day message you talked
about how this has been a really
unique opportunity like no other in many
ways where we have actually been able to
stop pause reflect
and and reset you alluded to some of
your
thoughts there but what do you think are
the key priorities the key themes that
we really need to be looking at
in a post-covid world
well first of all we need to work at how
do we
create the kind of recovery that
benefits people
helps to get people back to work again
provides
real employment around the world and
that can be done
of course by prioritizing certain things
that haven't been prioritized before
which is to recognize the damage being
done by
by co2 and this can be done in a way
that raises
enormous amounts of money it's already
done in certain countries i mean in the
eu
for instance they raised 40 to 45
billion
euros a year from just charging a price
of 24
euros a ton for carbon
if you increase that price you could use
that
money to help fund the the buildback in
a better way if you see what i mean
i was going to ask you it seems like
very long time ago but
but in january you launched the
sustainable markets
council a lot has changed since then is
it now time to to rip up the rule book
or are you still
feeling confident that that could be a
good basis for
for a global economic model going
forward
yes i think you can i mean i i've been
as i think i said before
i've been absolutely amazed by well the
transformation that's taken place in the
last year or two
in terms of the financial services
sector and the capital market
sector suddenly taking an interest in
sustainable investment opportunities
i mean i tried 12 14 years ago with
trying to bring in as many pension funds
as we could to look at
long-term sustainable investments for
instance in green bonds and
saving the rainforests all these things
which absolutely key to our survival
but every time we thought we were
getting somewhere
we somebody said oh but who's going to
underwrite the risk
the trouble is the risk has increased
150 vote or more
so we now are faced with a mounting
crisis so fortunately people are wanting
now increasingly to invest in a
sustainable way in a way that actually
produces and rewards best practice and
doesn't
worse practice we've got banks we've got
people like jp morgan with other leading
banks
are now saying that they won't they will
change their loan
lending policy to uh companies in the
oil gas and
coal sectors in such a way that they
won't loan the money unless there is
carbon capture and storage
built into their operations so
even even big you know
fossil fuel companies like shell bp and
exxon mobil
are all now recognizing that these
externalities need to be addressed and
that
that's why even they are saying carbon
pricing is something that matters
because the the big uh fossil fuel
companies
are the other a part of the solution
i understand that you you have been um
pleased to see that when people have
been talking about a post-covered world
there has been talk about
about a green recovery um
do we need more examples of of
governments
um encouraging businesses with within
incentives like we've seen in the past
be more green and we will we will back
you up we
will help you in these difficult times
yeah so and there are
and there are some very good examples
around the world of this
the thing is of course that um as i was
saying earlier you have to
you have to deal with the the many
perverse uh
subsidy regimes that exist whether it's
again in fisheries or forestry or
agriculture
at the moment all that's happening is
that
so much money is going into doing things
in the worst possible way
so we're actually shooting ourselves in
the foot most of the time
it's not rocket science to reorientate
those
perverse incentives to be beneficial
incentives um you know for instance
the rules all sorts of things are coming
up all sorts of companies and
governments are saying that they're
they're aiming for net zero by 2050
which sounds all marvelous but then
there are no at the moment most of them
don't have
uh particular targets they don't have uh
to report
on this at intervals to show what is
actually happening
simple things like that could make a
fantastic difference so that
shareholders consumers particularly
because people should remember that the
consumer has an immense
role to play in all this and more and
more young people are concerned as they
have been for many years
at last you know there is a chance
because all these
companies i've been talking to over the
and i've been
trying for 38 years to encourage
corporate social and environmental
responsibility
with only a few really in proportion to
the huge number around the world taking
any interest
now suddenly more and more really are
and they want to know how to do it so
there are people coming to
my sustainable markets initiative to to
to to help and support
do you appreciate that there is a fear
that that maybe this crisis has made
individuals less receptive to sort of
vision
visions of change many people are still
at home they'll be watching this
thinking well i'm still concerned my my
family could get ill
i'm concerned that i i don't necessarily
know whether i'm going to have a job
going forward
um what would you say what would you say
about that
yes but i totally understand all that
and the point about all this is that
whatever happens and if it does happen
the key the most important thing
obviously is to make sure the economy
can function again
and that people's livelihoods and their
businesses and everything else
and employment is is possible that all
these things are going to
have to be incremental anyway but the
point is that
in order to avoid even worse situations
in the future and more
disease and we have to we have to
find a way to ensure that within the
next 10 years because otherwise
we will lose this battle against
accelerating
climate change and and this and global
warming because
if we go on like this with temperatures
rising
inexorably then the whole of life
becomes
increasingly impossible do you fear that
you will be frustrated again that
the sort of global world will not come
together we haven't necessarily
we've seen in some ways countries have
closed their borders
uh countries have become more
inward-looking are you fearful that that
will
increasingly be the case as we move into
a post-covet world
yes there is always that risk and always
that that danger
but um i i mean i i am
i'm encouraged by the level of the
apparent level anyway of
willingness on the part of many people
to
to to look at this differently that the
problem is as you
identify is that we can't be certain
that other countries will
but but those that really want to do it
properly will
forge ahead anyway and and many
many will get left behind it seems to me
in an increasing backwater economically
and in other ways without understanding
the need to adopt this more integrated
and holistic
approach how much will you be pushing
for for global leaders to to step up
now and and come together at what is
a time when actually many countries
could feel disjointed and and be quite
inward-looking
as they try and fix their own their own
economies and and get out of this
pandemic
uh as individual nations well
um i haven't exactly been wasting my
time during this
lockdown if you know what i mean so i've
been you know
in connection with all sorts of people
i've had the opportunity to do a lot
using this technology i have been
communicating with a lot of people
around the world on these issues i've
been talking to
[Music]
to to to leaders in the caribbean
which is chiefly commonwealth countries
and they are facing immense challenges
i mean i was talking to um
the prime minister of saint lucia
recently because he
wanted to talk about the horrors facing
these countries and islands where the
tourism sector's disintegrated
completely they're
under the most appalling economic
pressure they've also got the risks and
dangers of every year
of hurricanes when they hit how do they
recover uh they're always in debt
and these are the issues that simply
have to be addressed on a
global scale there is the pacific
islands as well many of which are
common old countries all these small
island developing states are
absolutely critical so this is another
reason why i was trying
five six years ago to help build up
a commonwealth green finance facility
uh particularly to help these islands
these are all the sort of things that
now because we've got this catastrophe
on our hands suddenly
as so often happens it's only
catastrophes which concentrate the mind
which means that for once there might be
some real impetus to
tackle all these things which have been
pushed to one side
because everybody said no it's it's
irrelevant for instance
you could never get
[Music]
the g20 to concentrate very much on
agriculture forestry or fisheries
because it wasn't considered very sexy
but but these are crucial things you
you'd say that
this globally has affected everybody um
and it's affected everybody in very
personal ways for example
um you had the virus yourself how much
did that motivate you to
look at what can be done next and where
we go forward
yes it makes me even more determined to
push and shove and shout and
prod if you see what i mean and whatever
i can do
behind the scenes sometimes but but yes
i mean i i
i suppose it did partly i mean i was
lucky
in my case and um
and uh and got away with it quite likely
uh
but i've had it and um
[Music]
i cannot so understand what other people
have gone through and i
feel particularly for those for instance
who you know who've lost their loved
ones but
were unable to to be with them at the
time that's to me the most
ghastly thing but in order to prevent
this happening to so many more people
this is why
i'm so determined to find
a way how out of this in order to
bring the world and all of us back to
to the center back to understanding
what we have to do in relationship to
the natural world
i think what has struck me is that
there's been in some ways a great sense
of
of nostalgia people wanting to go go
back to how
things were i think ringing in
everyone's ears is that phrase we'll
meet again
um the virulence song but also used so
powerfully by
her majesty the queen in in her in her
message
will life as we knew it
ever return and and should it
well as i would say well
yes i mean a lot hinges doesn't it on on
finding a
a an effective vaccine and i mean i know
there are a lot of people working on
this
flat out and
some reports say they're very optimistic
well
that would revolutionize things but i
think the point about
all this is that as i was saying we
that what we need is to is to try and
rebuild people's hope we don't have to
stop doing everything
we can come back but in a far better way
that enables us to have
something very much approaching
normality
but but um for instance there's a lot of
work going on you know to ensure that
we could produce sustainable aviation
fuel for the aviation sector
biofuel made from waste there's huge
potential in the second
and even third generation biofuels which
could transform the situation i visited
the whittle
laboratory in cambridge earlier this
year to see what they're doing there on
on aero engines and the complete
transformation
and design of aircraft wings for
instance based on
what's called biomimicry so they've they
looked at
can you believe this that at the
[Music]
fins of whales moving through the water
and how they do it
without reducing the friction to and
they've been looking at how do you
design
aircraft wings to mimic natural things
like
whales or whatever it is remarkable what
can be done but we have to
bring the investment that's necessary
to do all this there's huge potential in
this carbon capture and storage we have
to do that if we're going to win the
battle to keep global temperatures
down uh to enable life to continue and
to enable biodiversity to continue
because if we go on doing it we create
all these endless diseases and problems
because we've destroyed the biodiversity
so
there is real hope in doing it better
and differently
as many people have been trying to say
all these years
but it'll be a new way but it enables
life to come back again
properly so there is hope but we're
looking at it at a
a new type of of normal as people people
are just desperate to see their families
really aren't they it's
it's a it's a challenging time well i
mean i haven't seen my father for a long
time and he's
he's going to be 99 next week and
uh so yes all my grandchildren are
anything so
i've been doing but the face time is all
real well
has that been for you being being
disconnected from your family if you
don't mind me asking
well i mean it's terribly sad that let
alone one's friends
but um i mean fortunately you know at
least you can
speak to them on telephones and
occasionally do this sort of thing but
it isn't the same is it you want to
you really want to give people a hug
yes i'd suspect you're not the only one
who who would love to to be able to to
embrace
their relatives and hopefully that time
it is coming very soon well i i do hope
so because
well i don't worry i totally understand
so many people's frustration
difficulties grief and anguish and
i mean i'm just trying to do my best to
find and help encourage
ways to enable people to go on doing
that but in a way that doesn't
wreck everything at the same time around
us
we can do it if we try
it's been absolutely fascinating talking
to you thank you very much
um for taking time and hopefully we we
will
all meet up again in in the ways that uh
that we usually do
so thank you very much sir i do hope so
anyway thank you brandon thank you
you